the movie starts with a sad funeral for
an old school principal named Jiang
xiaop young Hua a young and beautiful
woman is in charge of organizing the
funeral suddenly a suspicious reporter
named o shows up to pay his respects and
asks yanha about the principles cause of
death he finds the whole incident
strange because junk shop had cancer but
he died from something else and to add
to the mystery the old man has left all
of his fortune to Yan Hua even though he
didn't have any specific relationship
with her sounds like she may have been
scratching his back in the following
scene reporter o talks to Yan Hua for
some time but despite his efforts to
investigate further he is unable to find
any concrete Clues and beliefs later the
reporter seeks out Yan Hua again who is
placing some flowers over the grave and
discovers that she is living alone in a
Grand Mansion after sharing his reason
for investigation Yan Hua agrees to
comply with him for an interview she
then starts sharing the story of how she
met the old principal in the first place
following this the movie flashes back to
the past when yanhua used to work as a
caretaker after hearing about her
service the lonely old man Jiang xiaop
hires her and urges her to take care of
him during their first meeting Zhang
xiaop reveals that he is in the late
stages of cancer and doesn't have much
time left to live he also mentions that
he wants to spend his remaining days in
peace and asks yanwa to take care of all
his needs until then surprisingly
without any reluctance yanhwa agrees to
his request however during the initial
days jiangxia becomes increasingly
demanding and difficult to please he
gets angry easily if the food doesn't
meet his expectations and even asks Yan
Hua to give him long massages I'd have
been more surprised if he didn't go down
that road one night after having a
nightmare Zhang siop wakes up and finds
Yan Hua sleeping beside him instead of
watching over him seeing this he becomes
Furious and throws a glass of water at
her waking her up however the anwarf
remains calm and he eventually goes back
to sleep as the days pass nian Hua
learns jiangxiaop's preferences and
becomes more understanding of his name
she begins preparing his favorite meals
taking care of his medications plays
this little piggy went to the market
with him and even knowing the correct
temperature of water for his bath with
all of this their relationship improves
and they grow closer one night Jung shop
takes Yan Hua to a reunion party and
introduces her to his friends he even
convinces her to sing a song on the
stage which captivates everyone in the
audience jianxiop is really impressed by
her singing ability as he had no idea
about it on their way home he mentions
that the song used to be his late wife's
favorite when asked about how she knew
about the song Jan Foie confesses that
her late boyfriend used to listen to it
quite often the following morning Jan
Hua is giving jianxiap a pedicure in the
garden I was kidding about this little
piggy but here we go as the two grow
close the old man opens up about his
deceased son mentioning that he was
around Jan foie's age when he passed
away in an unfortunate accident he then
inquires why she is caring for him
instead of enjoying her youth elsewhere
in reply myan-hua offers a vague
response stating that she is simply
following her predetermined path of Fate
which is to become really rich ASAP the
next day Junction experiences a painful
episode due to his illness causing him
to scream in agony he falls from the bed
and crawls on the floor to get some
water to drink sadly even after drinking
he gets no relief hearing his screams
yantua rushes to his aid but he
dismisses her help and asks her to iron
his suit instead once the pain subsides
junk shop comes out of the room and
yonhua hands him the suit he then
instructs her to go outside on her own
and collect a photo from a studio in the
next scene as requested myanvoir steps
out of the house and heads towards the
photo studio little does she know that
jiangxiop has a chilling plan to commit
the unthinkable which is why he sent her
away while Yan hwa receives the photo at
the studio and thinks about jiangxiop a
sudden realization strikes her she
understands his intentions and rushes
back home desperately hoping to prevent
the tragic outcome luckily she arrives
in the nick of time and saves her
employer with tears streaming down her
face she she then Falls to her knees and
pleads with jiangxia to never do that
again in that very moment the old man
realizes that he now finally has someone
to live for as the days pass their bond
deepens and junk xiaop begins to
ReDiscover happiness one day as he is
organizing photographs of his late wife
and son he opens up to Yan hwa
confessing that everyone he has ever
loved has left him now he is fearful of
being abandoned once again however the
anwa tenderly assures him that she has
nowhere else to go and Promises to
remain by his side forever to shift the
conversation bring some Solace Yan Hua
gently inquires about Jon's son captured
in the photograph in reply he reminisces
about his sonnet describing him as a
dedicated and talented individual who is
tragically taken away by a car accident
leaving the world too soon the next day
Yan Hua accompanies Jiang xiaop for a
medical checkup and to their
astonishment the doctor delivers
unexpected news John Shop's cancer cells
have miraculously stopped spreading
instead of having only six months to
live he now has an extent ended
prognosis of six years the doctor
concludes that patients who maintain a
positive outlook on life tend to
experience longer life spans on their
way back from the appointment junk shop
can be seen smiling expressing his
gratitude to Yan Hua by holding her hand
he believes that she is the reason for
his happiness and positive attitude
towards life in the following days junk
Shop's affection for Yan Hua grows
stronger and he treats her to fancy
dinners at nice restaurants during one
of these dinners Yan Hua kindly advises
him to not drink too much because of his
illness however the old man who is
caught up in the moment completely
ignores her and ends up getting faced as
he gets drunk he tries to be intimate
with Yan Hua he grabs her in his arms
and tries to kiss her forcefully however
after a bit of a scuffle she manages to
push him away and stop him from doing
anything bad feeling disappointed Yan
Hua decides to leave the house leaving
jiangxiop Alone the movie then switches
back to the present with reporter o
leaving Yan hua's house the following
day he carries out some investigation
and discovers that before becoming
caretaker she used to work as an escort
desperate to uncover the truth reporter
o goes back to the mansion and
interrogates Yan Hua again this time he
looks around the house and stumbles upon
a photo of a man who seems familiar to
him he asks Yan Hua about the guy but
she brushes off the question and invites
him to stay for dinner later during the
meal the reporter straightforwardly asks
yonha if she has anything to do with the
old man's death in response yonghua
doesn't give a clear answer and instead
pours reporter owes some wine she then
shares more about her past with the old
man the movie once again flashes back in
time to the day when yanhua rejected the
old man's advances unfortunately this
sends him into a state of depression
because of which he starts treating her
poorly again to make matters worse Jung
siop's Health begins to decline despite
his mean Behavior Nyan Hua continues to
care for him but this time she does so
by wearing revealing clothes and
occasionally trying to seduce him she
massages him frequently and also puts
his head on her lap she also plays this
little pig with even more fervor back to
the present yanwa suddenly interrupts
her story and decides to share another
important incident from her past with
the reporter she tells him about the
night she met her ex-boyfriend for the
first time at the nightclub where she
used to work while serving a group of
men she finds him quiet and shy unlike
other loud and energetic men there Yan
Hua finds his demeanor appealing and
starts to take an interest in him later
that night she gets a sudden headache
and sits alone outside the club
coincidentally the same guy from before
notices her discomfort he comes close to
her and offers her some medicine to help
her feel better with his behavior the
anwa finds him very humble and sweet she
cannot help but laugh and call him
adorable later the guy proposes to her
to have dinner and they end up going out
for a meal together from here the
relationship starts and grows with every
other meeting back in the present
reporter o finds himself spending the
night at Yan hua's house after drinking
too much wine when he wakes up he hears
yanwa crying in the shower curious and
concerned he approaches her and she
opens up about some dark experiences
from her past she insists that she is
innocent and did not murder the old man
the reporter feels bad for her and tries
consoling her but one thing leads to
another and they end up getting intimate
surprisingly the following morning
reporter o wakes up to find Jan Hua gone
while searching for her around the house
he comes across an old news article that
reveals the truth about janwa's
boyfriend he goes through it and
discovers that her boyfriend was
actually the son of the old man jungshop
the article also reveals that her
boyfriend didn't die in a car accident
but committed the unthinkable frustrated
by a traumatic event confused by what he
just read the reporter decides to delve
deeper into the investigation he
uncovers the shocking fact that jan-hua
had been making potions potions I tell
you to induce feelings of love and she
had spiked both his and the old man's
drinks the scene shifts back to the past
and we see jiangxiaop carefully trimming
his beard seemingly preparing for
something special with a ring in hand he
enters Jan's room and gently places it
on her finger while she is asleep
however Young suddenly wakes up and
rejects his heartfelt proposal desperate
to win her over Chiang xiaop goes to
Great Lengths he offers her his house
and all of his fortune hoping that she
will agree to marry him however she
refuses all of his advances and leaves
him alone after several days yanhua
returns home with vengeance in her eyes
it is at this moment that she unveils a
shocking truth she is actually the
girlfriend of his deceased son yanwa
discloses her true intentions mentioning
that she has come for revenge for her
boyfriend's death it turns out that Yan
hua's boyfriend's tragic demise was a
result of his own father's deep-seated
hatred upon discovering his son's
relationship with an escort junk shop
orchestrated a cruel plan he hired some
of yan hua's previous clients and forced
them to engage in Intimate acts with her
while making his son watch everything I
could have sworn this was a love story
this inflicted painful scars on them
both in particular the boyfriend was so
deeply affected that he jumped in front
of a moving car and ended it all upon
learning the devastating truth
jiangxiaop collapses to the ground in
utter shock meanwhile Nyan Hua retreats
to a room seemingly happy that what she
has done the next day Zhang xiaop
requests a shower from yanhwa afterwards
while she is in another room he commits
the unthinkable leaving her alone with
his wealth and Fortune following this
Yan Hua is at a train station
contemplating on ending it herself
however when she tries to jump into the
oncoming train completing this cycle of
unbelievably depressing [__] she is
unexpectedly saved by the spirits of
Junk's Yap and her deceased boyfriend
they appear as ethereal beings offering
her Solace and guidance junk Shop's
Spirit assures Yan Hua that he Harbors
no grudges against her and encourages
her to live the remainder of her life to
the fullest using the property he had
left for her the movie ends with the
beautiful scene of jiangxiop and her
boyfriend's Spirits bidding farewell to
Yan Hua as they board a train they wave
at her signifying their support as she
embarks on a new chapter carrying their
memories with her but not all that dark
[__] from the last 10 minutes subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching